I'm trying to get some of these TVs in
the building turned off because you got
too many people talking on TV about us
and what they think about us what we
should do what we are what we're not but
they don't really know who we are or
what we're capable of people or what
we're going through what we're thinking
it's just the outside viewers looking in
and so yeah tunnel vision ear muffs and
just come to work every day and try to
get better and get back to what we know
we're capable of doing that's been true
for Biscay talking to reporters on
wednesday once the TV's turned off in
Hallas hall and look I think I know what
he was trying to do and it was kind of I
don't want to say tongue-in-cheek but
look it always bugs me when football
players or coaches get mad because those
of us who are paid to observe and
comment on what we see observe a bad
team and comment on how badly the team
is performing how dare we acknowledge
the obvious Chris so look I don't think
it it requires a PhD in high level
fandom to understand that the Bears
stink right now I don't know where Mitch
true Biscay wants people to say they're
great they're just misunderstood right
they're getting screwed by the refs no
they stink yeah no there's no doubt
about it and you know he you know he
himself is going in the wrong direction
this year the other offense has been
horrible
you know the defense is still really
good but they haven't been as dominant
because the offense is so bad this year
they're out there every fourth play of
the game so they wear down eventually so
it's yeah it's not a good look and you
know I understand like them not wanting
like turn the TV's off do that thing or
change the channel yeah there's a lot of
teams that do that especially when
they're struggling I mean I've been a
part of that I can remember a year in
Tampa where we were struggling and Jon
Gruden was walking out of the cafeteria
and turned the TV off because he just
didn't want to hear it like I think the
NFL Network was on at that time or
whatever it may be now I know other
organizations who don't have TVs in
their building to begin with anyways
where the players are you know lounging
around it's it's not about that you're
here to work we're not here to like sit
together and watch TV and and gossip and
talk about what's going on in the world
New England you know I don't know how
they've done with their
new facility I know they've redone stuff
up there but when I worked there there
was no TVs around guys weren't gonna be
sitting there listening to outside noise
and having conversations about oh this
guy said this and this guy said that so
it is something that is dealt with in
the building in different ways
throughout the NFL and and I'd like to
try to articulate a basic rule of thumb
that I had never really thought about
before yeah I think if a team is being
criticized undeservedly they use that
noise as motivation yes when a team is
being criticized for good reasons that's
when you just don't want to hear it
because they're right right I mean you
can use this bulletin board material
when you think that somebody's being
unfair in their criticism of a player a
coach a team whatever but when they are
dead-on accurate that's when you just
turn it off because you know it's
forcing you to look in the mirror and
you know it's not a pretty sight that's
exactly right you know a lot of you like
the Eagles two years ago with the Super
Bowl run right I mean they had the
confidence and knew at that point that
they were a really good team when Carson
Wentz got hurt so they weren't about to
go like oh we got to turn the TV off
teams are you know the people on TV are
telling us we have no chance of winning
with Nick Foles they were like no screw
that let's listen to these idiots talk
we're really awesome we're not just
about one player and they did rally
around that and the flipside yes usually
when teams are 2 and 5 or whatever it
may be 2 and 6 and just playing crappy
all together there's no defense of it
because usually that's the truth of the
matter you know players haven't played
well the coaches have messed up in
certain situations their schemes haven't
been good whatever it may be and yeah
that's when it doesn't become motivation
at all it becomes let's not listen to
the outside noise let's not start
fighting each other because of the
outside noise and see if we can rally
together just by let's get better here
in the building and practice and get on
our P's and Q's and cross our T's and
dot our eyes and all that crap now with
all that said yeah and the Bears turn it
around do you see anything there that
gives you hope that what Mitchell true
Biscay is saying is accurate and that
they know the team better than the rest
of us and that they are going to find a
way I mean you know it feels like there
Owen 8 they are through
five yeah did win three in a row and
they had a Lions team coming to town
that has found a way more often than not
to lose games that maybe they should
have won this year well I feel like it
doesn't really matter who they play
every games gonna be close cuz their
offense isn't capable of blowing anybody
out of the water so and I don't really
have the confidence that their offense
is gonna come through really at this
point in late-game situations to win
football games and what's scary too is
even when they do come through let's
just say and get a lead you know we've
seen here this year where the defense is
too exhausted at that time to hold the
lead down anyways you know whether it be
the Raiders game in London that's the
one that jumps out to me more than
anything but you know I look at their
schedule and just go man okay they're
you know the Lions the Giants the Lions
again you know those are teams that I
could say yeah make it beat them but
they could very easily lose because
their offense is capable of laying an
egg there's still no identity and then
when you talk about Chiefs Vikings Green
Bay Dallas Cowboys and Rams I go know
those teams are better than the Chicago
Bears and it's going to take a defensive
pick six or a fumble or a short field or
things like that for them to win those
type of games in my opinion yeah and
here's the problem the NFC has so many
great teams is sheer right they're gonna
have to run the table or come damn close
to so Bears want to get back to the
playoffs seven and one yeah I think
minimum nine and seven is probably not
going to get you in in the NFC this year
and they've got the Vikings and the
Packers on their own division they got
the Packers again this year they they
got to go to Lambeau Field and play
Green Bay they've got to go to Minnesota
and play the Vikings it would be and
every year there's a team hovering
around 500 that finds the gas pedal in
November and takes off it would be a
stunner if the Bears are the ones who do
it because we've seen the bodywork so
far yeah not good yeah
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports